[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
I am in Las Vegas for CES 2013 and today
was day one and I was at invidious press
conference today as you can see by the
title so thumbs up for that but
basically Nvidia definitely pulled a
classic Apple keynote today but it was
pretty awesome but they really did they
started off really slow giving us to
know the basic announcements they
revisited some old technologies they
came back to cloud gaming so they
announced some new hardware that really
enhances the ability to play games using
streaming for more powerful hardware but
then they introduced what you know the
product that we were all waiting for was
and then wrapped it all up with a one
more thing in a product that we weren't
expecting at all so they really did a
really great job so without any further
ado I'm going to go ahead and kick it
off and show you guys what happened at
the Nvidia keynote which i think was the
most impressive part of CES day one
let's take a look so yeah like I said it
started off pretty slow at least
compared to the rest of the action and
if you're a gamer it started off
especially slow because we all knew what
was coming we are all looking forward to
the Tegra 4 processor but instead they
started off with the cloud stuff they
introduced something called GFE or
GeForce experience which we'll take a
look at the game you're playing and the
specs of your machine and basically max
out the settings that your computer can
handle to still have a playable
framerate so that was kind of cool they
also introduced their own version of
cloud gaming where graphics are rendered
on NVIDIA servers somewhere and not on
your own device so that you can have
amazing quality graphics hi front high
frame rates and everything like that
without an expensive gaming machine
thanks to the cloud and they call this
the grid which was basically racks on
racks of custom Nvidia graphics cards
but they got to the good stuff pretty
fast it was the brand-new and video
Tegra 4 self-proclaimed the fastest
mobile processor out there and it was
pretty impressive from what we saw is a
quad-core chip again similar to the
Tegra 3 with a flip companion core that
runs the background tasks and handles
everyday stuff just like we saw in the
Tegra 3 this guy has 72 graphics cores
and does support 4G so we'll probably
see it in devices in the first half of
2013 they also compared it to other
popular tablets that are already on sale
and it's even so fast that it's
basically able to take an HDR shot and a
single burst normally when a device
takes HDR it takes to a bright image
saves it takes a dull image saves that
and then combine them together and gives
you a final result that's what HDR is
type 4 is able to do that
instantaneously which is pretty cool and
lets you basically use HDR for any shot
you want
they also ended that demo with taking a
picture on a tablet so yeah anyway then
they pulled the one more thing which was
cool and they introduced a Tegra 4 based
mobile gaming console looked pretty much
like an enhanced Xbox 360 controller
with a 5 inch 720p multi-touch display
attached pretty much destroys the WiiU
from what we saw it also has HDMI out
and they demoed it the entire time
outputting video to a 4k display so the
graphics looked insane
and it also has full-size USB and
expandable storage via micro SD cards
you can also take advantage of that
cloud gaming technology we talked about
earlier and you can play games using
Nvidia's grid or even your own computers
GTX graphics card which is pretty
awesome the only thing they didn't
mention about this is the price it'll be
available in the second quarter of 2013
from what we've heard and my guess it
will be somewhere around $400 but you
can feel free to leave your estimates in
the comments below either way that's
basically what we saw for n videos press
conference on CES day 1 that's it
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you